st. Joseph's Hospital in Kitgum northern
Uganda here some 200 patients are
receiving treatment of the wounds they
sustained during the Lord's Resistance
Army insurgency millions were massacred
mutilated tortured enslaved and raped in
the conflict between the LRA and
government troops Victor auction and his
organization African Youth Initiative
Network provides support for victims who
until now have never seen a doctor such
as Amara dreams omana James was abducted
from a BIA and he spent about seven
months in captivity so while he was in
captivity would be made to walk long
distance but then as a process of
torture the the rebel kept on piercing
his leg with the bionics I have no
problem with forgiving those who injured
me as long as I'm healed it depends on
my ability to become normal again that
defines whether or not I can forgive
come on Betty come dig Araucana cover up
a Amara James will walk again Victor
uses these success stories to convince
the UN and the European Union to fund
his project he grew up in the midst of
the violence and later worked as a
journalist and reported from the
conflict zone ten years ago Victor quit
his radio job to fully commit to his
organization many victims have not
forgotten what happened to them
how can you make peace tangible to
people who have suffered injustice and
that's why we say heal people physical
injuries help them heal emotionally
it'll hop in the space for historical
dialogue a difficult dialogue the
dialogue that might be going through
layers and unveiling many untold painful
stories in February 2004 LRA troops
stormed a via Victor's hometown and
massacred hundreds of people many were
abducted including Victor's older
brother Omar Jeffrey here at the
memorial site the people of Abia
commemorate those who were lost the
country has lost just too much the deep
rooted deep baited hatred in the country
needs a prospect for national
reconciliation
[Music]
for Betty atoms peace only arrived when
she returned from hospital last year as
a single woman with a septic gunshot
wound to her ankle she was shunned by
the whole village until Betty got help
from a unit came back from the hospital
the biggest change in my life was that I
felt accepted again in the community
previously I was alone I would walk in
public and everyone would walk away from
me
I could smell myself everybody turned
away I was stigmatized and not accepted
not even in the church or in the market
nowhere I smelled so badly now what I
wrong today Victor is sending off
another truckload of patients everybody
is happy to get home and work the fields
again without pain let us try to make
peace a reality not only purpose we can
sign treaties we can sign constitution
and put in the cupboard if it does not
transform life that is not peace to us
in 2015 Victor was nominated for the
Nobel Peace Prize since then he has
turned down prestigious job offers
abroad because he knows that Uganda's
wounds are still a long way from being
healed